very much Michael and thank you all for
coming and delighted to see so many of
you here but about myself I'm a curator
as michael has suggested and I work in
the Victoria and Albert Museum in London
and I sit in a quite recently
established department called design
architecture and digital now we've been
in post 3 years which in kind of Silicon
Valley terms is quite a long time but in
museum terms in an institution that has
over 160 years history we are still very
new we're just scratching the surface
it's my first time in Stamford and I'm
really happy to be able to share some of
the work that we are doing with you so
when I sent my abstract over i listed a
series of objects that I had a curator
have sought to acquire now they include
the Lego Research Institute which is the
first in the Danish company's history to
feature women in a professional context
targeted at girls and the world's first
3d printed farl a liberator so termed
and called by its creator Cody Wilson
who at the time was a text and law
student or we still text him when he was
a law student at the time and flappy
bird which again took a long time to get
into the museum to the extent that we
had to translate a letter into Chinese
then Vietnamese via three friends of
mine it made headlines as one of the
most frustrating games and the anger
that it brought about was very much what
led to it being removed from the app and
Google Play stores for me as a curator
to find a way to display that in the
museum led to my trying to find the best
player in an institution made of
curators our apprentice electrician was
short be the one to be able to do it six
points with what he could manage this is
a set of christian louboutin shoes in
five ethnically diverse shades of nude
note the word some broken umbrellas from
hong kong mon one which is a wee chat
enabled soft toy marketed at parents
living away from home Chinese parents
predominantly and the other objects that
I
to that list were the ones that have
proved elusive a set of broken computer
parts that at one time held a copy of
the NSA and other files leaked by Edward
Snowden and the infamous VW defeat
device how do I go about collecting that
what is it we'll come on to that um I
think at this point it would be a very
reasonable question for one of you to
say what are you doing what do these
modest sometimes modest very diverse
objects have in common and what place do
they have in a museum and in this case
the world's first design museum the
Victoria now but how many of you
actually have been there also quite a
few grapes those of you who haven't we
are an institution known for its grand
galleries and collections of decorative
arts and design but also its blockbuster
exhibitions of David Bowie or Alexander
McQueen um but I think all that said we
do have a much much more radical past
and this is important in the work that I
do but also the work that my team does
the fries that you see here kind of
encapsulate that radical moment this is
the museum's original front entrance and
it's our founding despite the UK or
Great Britain depending how you want to
term it depending on your loyalties in
terms of the Royals if birth despite us
being the birthplace of the Industrial
Revolution at the point in the 1850s the
UK was being outdone or flogged if you
want to use those terms in terms of
industrial design by the French the
Germans the Americans you name it
everybody else was appearing to do it
better Prince Albert therefore organized
what was the world's first Great
Exhibition of the world's first Expo in
1851 and this was a means to address
this seeming incapacity in design
quality and design terms in the UK so
here you can see Queen Victoria
here we go our great monarch standing in
front of what is Joseph Paxton's Crystal
Palace so the black outline is the great
glass palace in which this exhibition
was hosted and she's seen receiving the
nation's bringing their best art science
and design this exhibition was such a
success that the museum the Victoria and
Albert Museum was its result we are also
part of Alberta Palace which includes
the Royal Colleges of art music and
dance science but also the other larger
London institutions the Natural History
Museum and the science museum so 1851
was when we were founded and it was with
a mission for contemporary design to
collect it as an educational resource
for manufacturers designers and the
public and in museum terms that's quite
important because at this point museums
were not necessarily for the every
person Henry cold who is our very
charismatic first director put it more
succinctly it was to be the powerful
antidote to the gin Palace so rather
than going drinking in the evenings you
might find yourself taking advantage of
an institution that has the first to be
a place of learning for all and that
meant having gas lighting extended
opening hours and indeed a cafe where
you could sustain yourself prior to
having a look and improving your lot the
vmas foundation I think you can term it
in it as a place to help navigate the
anxieties of what was brought about by
industrialization so it's an output or
an outcome of the Industrial Age and
this this usefulness this radicality is
something that I and my colleagues in
the design architecture and digital
department very much motivated by so
since being in post in early 2013 we
have as a team of curators being tasked
with looking at the design world of
fresh and rapid response collecting was
our first act of this kind of radicality
if you want to put it in those terms
it's a new strand the museum's wider
collecting activity
we are an institution with 3.5 million
plus objects some of which are more than
7,000 years old so you have to
understand that rapid response is one of
its activities as the name suggests it's
simply about getting the thing itself
into the museum quickly this may seem
obvious but museums as I've already in
some ways suggested do move quite slowly
but it's also about thinking what the
museum is for and what public
institutions do in wider civic
infrastructure but also in the world in
which we live and learn all the objects
that we acquire to our mind are objects
that are part of public discourse and by
bringing the object itself into the
museum and it is at this point in time
so often a physical object but not only
and I think every object that I'm
talking about today is a digital object
but we can come on to that in the
questions and conversation afterwards
and so we think we can deepen
understanding by showing the thing
itself at this point I'd like you to
understand that it's quite a modest
project rapid response there are five
showcases and 12 objects on display at
any one time and when we got our gallery
we were delighted we have about eight
miles of galleries in the museum and our
space is one that leads to another but
it was our own it's quite a modest
budget which meant lining a set of cases
in metal and buying a printer to print
our own magnetic labels this means that
we can get objects on display in days or
weeks instead of months or years all
that is the ambition so rapid response
opened to the public in July 2014 and
the response has ranged from the
indifferent to the outraged em to the
sensational of course I like this almost
but ultimately rapid response is about
placing questions of our relationships
to new objects and new technologies in
the public realm and so let's come on to
a number of the objects that we've
acquired and I start with the firearm
because it's already featured in a
number of the slides that we've been
looking at
so on the fifth of may 2013 Cody
successfully fired the first entirely 3d
printed firearm many this couldn't be
done a moment celebrate for its maker
but could this plastic firearm have
grave implications for gun control
around the world so there is the
question it was released online for free
this 3d file and the State Department
had forced or requested that Cody take
it down within days and it was very
available on piratebay how we source our
objects is one question that we might
come too but then within within weeks we
sent one of our colleagues off to see
Cody in his studio to secure objects for
the museum and I think while I'm talking
about it think about this object in
digital terms it's of interest because
it is a multiple and that you can create
it at the press of the button but here
we are as museum curators flying across
the pond to try and get the physical
thing that said we it secured the object
with Cody and it was really one of our
very first acts of rapid response
collecting and frustratingly it was not
so rapid in the end because it took more
than a year to get the object into the
UK and on display in the museum so here
you have it being shipped as fine art
and arriving in October 2014 and the
reason for this was that the export of
this firearm necessitated a change in US
law because a plastic firearm fell
without the legal frameworks of
governance at the time of export and I
think if you think about these objects
in those terms that is absolutely part
and parcel of its interest for us and in
the wider context we as curators
immediately thought that this was a
fundamentally important piece of
contemporary design history in having
that physical thing in the museum we can
both show its design brilliance in terms
of it being a fantastically engineered
piece of work
but also its absolute an immediate
failure fire it three times and it
breaks if you want a proper gun there
are other ways to go about it for Cody
this was a political act for us in terms
of rapid response it's an object that
has forever changed our understanding of
distributed manufacturing it's about
regulation and the law and new depth on
new technologies and how they have broad
ramifications it was one that blew the
techno utopianism around 3d printing out
of the water and I think we are still
experiencing the consequences of this
and I don't think that's an
overstatement for this object Rapid
Response objects as a whole are
important and interesting to us because
they are material evidence physical
evidence at the moment of social
political economic and technical change
they are newsworthy and I think that's
part of what rapid responses success has
been generated by but they are much more
so about showing advances in design but
also objects that can reveal truths
about how we live together today another
one of the objects that I'd like to
consider as a digital object but also to
focus in on is a set of two painted
umbrellas so sitting in London we were I
in particular observed the political
disk wire in hong kong in late-september
2014 I'm sure that most of you are many
of you aware that tear gas was used to
counteract citizens of Hong Kong in the
streets protesting for what they
consider to be democratic law they very
rapidly became known as all this set of
this protest became known as the
umbrella revolution and for us this was
again a functional object we are a
design institution and every object that
we acquire first and foremost has to be
something of design but here we have a
functional object that has taken on
political meaning we asked a local
academic and contact of ours to help us
find an umbrella
at the time king sent us images of tents
tote bags and other objects or
accoutrements accessories that have been
made from recycled umbrellas but we were
firm in our desire for an object and
that was useful and it was a useful
object that had been invested with a
deeper meaning it became a shield from
tear gas as well as from rain so we saw
two of the painted umbrellas there were
very many painting umbrellas but we
managed to find two located or we I say
King managed to find them for us painted
umbrellas at this recycling point that
was run by students who were very very
prominent within these protests at the
Occupy admiralty site and I rather liked
that picture because it really brings
home the object that we now have in the
collection i should say they were
painted with the symbol kang which means
to support to protect or to persevere
but some King on once having collected
these objects he started to look at them
a little bit more closely and he's an
inquisitive individual very much
interested in popular culture and has an
anthropological bent so if you notice
you'll see a small screen printed guy
holding an umbrella aloft and for King
this was a lead and a number of days
later I received an email from from ye
in a young advertising executive and I'm
just going to read a quote from the
email the umbrella revolution started on
a Sunday afternoon we were shocked by
the tear gas but the citizens were so
angry they were not frightened and more
and more people rushed to the street the
next morning I brainstormed with my
friends we wanted to do something to
gain more support we saw the term
umbrella revolution created by the
Foreign Press to try and name this
protest movement we decided to design
and produce umbrellas and shoot a short
video asking people from different
countries to hold an umbrella to support
us our objective was to gain more
international support hoping that in
many that it may put more pressure on
the government
so again and 20 of his friends and
colleagues collected as many umbrellas
as they could from local retailers
turned out around 500 and painted and
printed them by hand by Tuesday so
within days they were ready to shoot the
video and with the help of those in
Causeway Bay they filmed the umbrellas
being held aloft to the shaft of true
universal suffrage
and at this point just to come back to
you in and what he thought and I focused
quite a lot to come back to yin and his
email I focus quite a lot on his
correspondence because for me this is an
integral part of the object and our
understanding of it and so he remembers
it vividly this point after the video
was shot it was a very emotional moment
it started to rain we left all the
umbrellas at the supply center run by
the student in dad morality all of the
people involved in the project including
the van driver refused to take any money
I felt very grateful to everyone and of
course this is the point where King
finds them at the recycling point for me
as a curator I wanted those umbrellas in
the museum that they then had this
international dimension this lens this
virtual I mean the fact that the
umbrellas had become symbolic fire
distributed media network was absolutely
clear but then that we happened by
chance to come across these objects
where yin had very much with intention
created something that was for the kind
of viral video or the viral press or
media circus with some super interesting
and again it's about these objects often
museums get told the objects once
they're in the collection they die and
you arrest their life but I'd like to
think that there are curatorial
strategies and approaches that remove
that i would say antiquated approach but
these are some of those examples and i
think one of the questions might be is
are these digital objects more likely
more prone to have this afterlife post
entry into the collection and the other
thing about this umbrella is it's now in
Sydney in an exhibition that looks at
objects and their role in bringing about
social and political change it's a
modest thing and actually one of them is
really quite broken but for me these are
objects that tell us about local
politics and citizen action but also
about the freer flows of information how
stories are made and constructed and
what the internet or our networked
society has or enables
I noticed that quite a few of you are
working on drones so this feels like a
good time to be here because this is our
most recent acquisition do any of you
recognize it so this is a Europe's
biggest Kickstarter project it had
12,000 backers and funded to the figure
of 3.5 US dollars 3.5 million u.s.
dollars so this was 20 times its
original goal it's the xeno micro drone
and it was launched in November last
year no sorry 2014 in North Wales so in
the UK self-taught engineer with a
mission to build a marketable
intelligent autonomous drone it was as
Kickstarter sensation as they are
increasing in number but the project
quite soon ran into trouble on the 18th
of november of last year the company
talking group had gone into voluntary
liquidation with millions of pounds
spent and very very few drones shipped
so now's a no was not only Europe's
largest Kickstarter project but the
crowdfunding platforms most spectacular
blow out to date Kickstarter
commissioned the investigative
journalist mark harris to establish what
went wrong um which I think in their
terms was a very enlightened thing to do
and it's also where I came to can't get
much much more interested in this story
he wrote thirteen thousand words and
within those thirteen thousand words he
concludes and that it was a more Rafael
up than foul play so the fact that this
never happened wasn't because they were
embezzling funds but because they
couldn't meet the demand of this wildly
successful crowd funding campaign the
founder of company just did not have the
experience to mass-produce objects of
this number I think one of the things
that is important with the xeno story is
the complicity of the media so this
object went on to be named as a top
object best design at CES in 2015 it
never flown and it did not fly once at
CES any of you who have been to CES will
be very aware that there are many many
drones that do fly and I think one of
the broader questions around this and
why this object is interesting and
important to me is this won't believe of
the digital we are not yet tooled up to
be as critical as we might be of these
types of projects and objects is that
what the role of the museum is perhaps
so very very few of them actually
shipped and I'm quite delighted but this
sitting next to our vendors toaster is
our latest acquisition and it this is an
object that in the museum enables us to
look at crowd crowd funding in the round
it sits alongside the oculus rifts and
the pebble watches which of course as
you will know are the great successes
Kickstarter's aim and purpose is to UM
bring creativity to life and this direct
digital connection between maker and the
community or the consumer is something
that is changing design practice but
also the retail or the purchase
experience and I think this is something
that we are at the advent of and we need
to be able to look at and take seriously
this is an object that through material
evidence enables to us to do so Yancey
Strickler who is one of the cofounders
of Kickstarter brilliantly Wroten or
reply to the journalist mark harris so
the journalist took his findings to
Kickstarter and it's interesting to read
in the article how Kickstarter responds
or how open they are to some of his
findings and then to me one of the most
memorable quotes is from Yancey if you
want hundred percent success with
hardware and new products I think the
only solution is that you just shop on
amazon and already that the suggestion
is Amazon is some a marker in time and
so
I noticed that one of you was working on
this idea of failure and the creative
outputs and outcomes of failure and we
want to acquire those I think museums
particularly design museums are very
much prone to acquiring or looking at
the great successes of the name designer
but I think failures such as this drone
but also the sinister as you might
consider the Liberator are as important
because these outliers are as important
as conventional design successes because
these outliers are often the things that
help us to think most most clearly about
how we interact today and it's also not
necessarily the kind of insight and
approach to those objects that we are
taking is not necessarily the intent of
the designer or the manufacturer and I
think museums more generally also and
when we talk about design architecture
the making process it's not about or
solely about the intent of those who
make things and I'm looking at you as
well who are I think on the making side
of this and so the intent of the
manufacturer or the designer and how we
might look at that so I'm here we have
the VW defeat device now this is
happening that is to date proved elusive
to me in terms of requiring it for the
collection but I think this is a digital
object again it absolutely is but what
do we think it is it speaks to our
changing relationships to machines and
engineering our use of cars and our care
or concern for the environment these are
huge abstract questions but they're all
impacts on each one and every one of us
every day I've been speaking about the
rain a great deal in a british fashion
over the last number of hours but i
think the rain here in California is one
of those things that we can relate back
to an object such as this um but how do
we work out what the VW defeat device is
I'm not the only one and by no means the
most expert person trying to work that
out but in terms of museums and
collecting what is it that we should
collect is it the car the engine the
line of code
or the trunk mounted equipment used to
carry out the emissions test which
firmly established that the defeat
device was a thing and the question
that's at the heart of this deceit is
what is it because that's exactly why VW
or the scam was possible I certainly but
I think very many of us have absolutely
no idea of what we're looking at when we
open up the bonnet to the car and so for
me this object and its appearance and
its occurrence in 2015-16 is about our
changing relationship to cars
manufacturing but also that we are at a
point in shift cars are becoming more
generic we will be seeing different
types of cars going forward and these
are the types of objects that when we
look at trying to corral design history
that can tell us a great deal today but
also in museum terms we're responsible
for these objects in the here and now
but also for their understanding and
thinking about their understanding in
the future so if it is a line of code
what might we do to collect that but in
display terms is that the most
interesting thing that we acquire and if
it's not what else do we acquire around
the object to capture that social and
interactive or haptic experience of the
object I like the idea of bringing a car
into the museum I have written to a
number of people to try and get an
object of this description into the
collection but my most promising lead is
going to the local VW dealership where
the recall is dealing with actually
swapping those objects in and out
whether that's the most meaningful thing
to acquire is something I'm not yet sure
of and I would also ask you to think
about but you will see that it's a great
deal about legwork and I guess there is
an investigative lens to what we are
doing through rapid response and I think
that's that's not surprising in the
sense that it's about going beyond the
laudatory and another or the last of the
elusive objects that I will talk about
today
so here we have the front page of The
Guardian newspaper on the twentieth of
august 2013 and you'll see there's a
small article or a small flash point at
the bottom of the page which talks about
a set of computers being destroyed at
the hands of the US sorry the UK
intelligence agencies so this after this
story was run I immediately wrote to the
Guardian editor to say can we have those
broken computers he's like yes sure
they're broken but then things got
complicated so these are computers that
the Guardian used to store and work on
the sets of files that were leaked by
Edward Snowden and the Guardian by no
means had the only copy of these
documents but these were the London copy
oh well this computer or set of
computers held the London copy and I
wrote to resp Bridger because for me it
was immediately obvious that these were
very very powerfully communicative
objects about the struggle for control
over the digital realm the world in
which we live in the data that we
inevitably give forth from ourselves on
a daily basis um at the at the Victorian
Albert Museum I i was quite new in the
museum at the time and only afterwards
did I say I've just written to get these
computers into the collection and it
caused quite a lot of discussion once
the editor had said yes at the Guardian
it was about actually establishing if
they could guarantee the legal status of
the object because it became ever more
complicated even though these were
destroyed computers they were still ones
that had held privileged information so
they were thinking about whether they
could give them to us but as
interestingly for me my colleagues and
my senior colleagues did force quite a
discussion that why they were relevant
to the institution and so the
conversation became about the purpose of
the museum which
something that I will return to and so
our governments the UK government wanted
these computers they understood them to
be rightfully theirs because they held
information that had been taken without
permission The Guardian said absolutely
not they are ours and so they arrived
after quite considerable discussion and
the threat of closure of the newspaper
at a compromise whereby these computers
were destroyed and this is a short video
that's slightly later but it does give
you some idea um it's harder to break up
a smash up a computer than you might
think the paper which had other copies
of the Snowden files overseas agreed to
take an angle grinder to the computer
while the intelligence agents watched
and for me it's I mean I see some of you
smiling there's a level of disbelief but
I find it totally amazing that there is
an idea that the destruction of these
computers is in any way meaningful the
Guardian journal editor himself said it
was a pointless act of symbolism because
it was clear that there were multiple
copies of these computers of these files
across the globe and thus Guardian was
certainly going to continue to report on
the story and this is the point at which
the Guardian linked up with the New York
Times because the way the press works
here is in a freer means than we have in
the UK and so here we are this is the
macbook air data was subject to such
brute force we've spoken a little bit
about their actual existence and for the
VNA so it was also it was why were these
objects relevant to the museum rapid
response collecting at this point in
time was very new yes at the Museum we
had the support for our activity but
we're a big institution we have 120
curators and there are different types
of committees and lobby groups that you
have to go through to get your
activities endorsed so yes we were
acting on the authority of the
institution but this was very much an
act of collecting that put the question
of the museum at its heart why was this
a piece of contemporary design that was
relevant it was totally broken that was
the view and the newsworthiness was also
a problem of course the VNA is a public
national institution would we in some
ways be considered to be upsetting our
paymasters i as a new curator at the
time had not necessarily considered
these wider ramifications as much as I
should and I actually think that's a
good thing because I don't feel that
those concerns were relevant in this
case
the question but in this case is the
design to object the computer for the
design like the design destruction of it
well I mean both I mean in terms of
objects in the museum we always look for
provenance and provenance is why this
particular object is interesting so the
act of its destruction is what makes
this particular example interesting but
then had we been able to acquire this
into the collection I said that this was
elusive we would certainly have acquired
a macbook air of the same generation to
sit alongside the act of its destruction
is what makes it interesting and you
could say that was its process of design
and it was very amusing but also
fascinating to watch the IT specialist
from the Guardian come in and see their
work sit alongside what in a context
where you do still understand objects to
be examples of great designers so it's a
fluid answer and I don't think there
needs to be a singular one but just to
come back to whether we could acquire it
on the basis of my colleagues it was the
insight and expertise of a medieval
sculpture colleague that led to one of
our most convincing lines of
justification we are a museum rich with
objects that have been subject to damage
this is a limestone British altarpiece
from the 14th century where the heads of
each of the Saints was knocked off in
the 16th century as a result of the
Reformation or image breaking in those
terms when there was a shift in Vice in
the church so here we have and I think
they're quite beautiful but again I've
just said as a curator I'm trying to
move away from this idea of
connoisseurship and the kind of primacy
of the aesthetic so we had our
historical precedent that these objects
because they were destroyed were
communicative about the new realities of
the digital age it still took us two
years from my first email not so rapid i
would say again english i get back to
get these objects into the museum
so this Guardian computer and we
actually these Guardian computers i
should say we also had a western digital
hard drive alongside the macbook air so
one was a solid state hard drive one was
a platter drive again changing
technologies and another lens through
which to look at these objects so cute
orally in terms of rapid response these
computers were both our greater success
to date but also our greatest failure
and so the Guardian decided to keep them
for themselves in the end which was a
great have to say disappointment but
also a recognition of the power of the
object to tell stories and their
acknowledgement of that we were able to
exhibit them in a display called ways to
be secret which form part of a larger
exhibition that my colleagues and I
curated last year called all of this
belongs to you all of this belongs to
you was an exhibition about the role of
museums in 21st century civic life but
also how design and architecture inform
an impact on our lives of citizens it
was also this question of what our
obligation is as a public institution to
further or enhance or be involved in
public discourse and I think for some
the idea that the museum is an active
agent within these contemporary or
political issues is quite a stretch we
have a museum that was founded on those
principles and a group of curators who
are quite keen in bringing some of that
back so ways to be secret as you can
just see a few of the objects here
brought around the Guardian computers
together a set of objects that try to
bring to the front of our visitors minds
what's at stake in our digital network
live so you went from the selfie stick
through to the Guardian computers and a
set of military-grade mobile phones that
are from what we understand the most
secure on the market to date all of
these objects have entered into the
collection and so you can say that
within the collections of the VNA this
moment of realization of questions of
privacy data ownership
right to freedom of expression are
marked with in our collections at the
time of the opening the editor of The
Guardian very much acknowledged that
having the objects on display in a
public national civic institution was
important and his views were I think
this is a message of hope it allows for
a continuation of what was a necessary
debate a debate that had to be had
because this is our data the data
belongs to us and these continue to be
really important questions for design
the digital but also you and I using our
mobile phones and in some ways having
them as the extension of ourselves who
owns our data web privacy are questions
that we cannot escape today and I would
argue that they become much more real
for those of us who are less familiar
with the subject when you see an object
such as a macbook air something that we
very regularly used conduct our daily
lives and having been subject to such
extreme force one of the things that for
me became particularly interesting with
these objects and working with a group
called privacy international is that you
see that every element of the computer
had some form of action on it so even
the heatsink and the fan and so ah and
this is a slight aside but our
intelligence agency the British
intelligence agencies but I think you
could make that a broader take very
rarely leave evidence of their actions
but because of the insistence of the
Guardian that these objects were not to
be given over and not to be fully
destroyed we now have a set of parts
that can be used forensic ly to track
back to think about is there something
being stored on other parts of our
computers it's a quite technical field
but one that has been begun to be
researched via these parts so again it's
that long tail of objects and the
material thing the thing about this
computer is also it was about rapid
response having a impact on the wider
activity of the institution
so this was a display and active
collecting more broadly so in effect
product design with a lens towards
security and surveillance that was made
possible through this first approach to
the computer so just to think about
rapid response in that broader context
is something that I mean as I said it's
12 objects at any one time in five
showcases so it's quite a modest thing
but we've been extremely privileged and
honored i think is maybe the better word
in the level of interest it has
generated i think in part it's because
it's reinforced the great power of the
material thing to tell political and
social stories even material things when
it pertains to the digital that is a
very museum based approach and I think
it's one that we will shift from but it
has proved useful to date I mean just to
come back to flappy bird yes we have
acquired the API files but we also have
two mobile phones that were very common
examples of what the game was played on
that we also have in the collection but
we cannot guarantee that those phones
will work forever but we do have an
engagement and a responsibility to make
sure that flappy bird in some form will
be playable into the future um museums
are uniquely placed much of what we and
again that sounds as a curator to say
that is to sound like i am not cognizant
of the kind of wider world but as we do
live in a very networked in digital age
or increasingly so we are ever more
being told that museums are seen as
places of trust places of facts and
places of authority it's almost as
though because we are a bit slower or we
are working with real things that people
seem to trust us more of course i like
to think that that is true because it
helps me and what i do and so it's not
to say that i buy that wholesale but i
think it's an interesting lens and
context within which to think of rapid
response collecting and what we do here
you can see how we exhibit the object
what we do
is include a short text about why the
object is important at this point in
time as in the point of interest so with
flappy bird it would have been the
moment in time when it was removed from
purchase but it's also to say what is it
it they're all nodes in these much
bigger more complex systems and we try
and signal that within 150 words but
rapid response is at no point trying to
tell you what to think about
globalization or the aggregation of data
it's a fact based approach which offers
our visitors a set of entry points into
these larger debates and it's where we
hope that our visitors imaginations take
flight and one of the oh now that we've
been doing rapid response for two to
innovate years and it is ongoing now
that we have started it we have a
responsibility for it to continue one of
the challenges to think about is how
digital is it so many of the objects now
that we've collected 2020 something you
begin to think of as a digital lens to
that is that because I'm always
researching on the internet is it
because all objects are digital but one
of the great challenges to us is not to
just repeat cultural mores it would be
very easy to have the kind of tumblr in
the museum sector and that's absolutely
not our goal or ambition um going
forward it is to ask the question of
what is our role as cultural producers
and I would also task you with thinking
what is my role in what I do how can we
distill information and as active
listeners or active makers offer up the
tools for our public's or our users to
decide if and when redress should begin
and how does that fit with the role of
the museum as a public institution
should we be there to try and be an
agent of change and active i activate
redress and I think my view would be yes
but I'm only one curator of many within
our institution the V&A was founded in
response to the anxiety is brought about
by the industrial age and I think much
of the work that we are doing with rapid
response but also with our forthcoming
exhibitions about the future of
design which will include this quite
incredible Facebook drone which will
bring the Internet to areas where
infrastructure is not yet in place solar
charged it's an amazing object and
actually being made in the UK so
bringing these objects into the museum
into a civic space to offer them up for
discussion so the VNA industrial Lang's
age anxieties we are also building a new
museum in East London which will be
significant in size and you might say
this is one or our mother ship in South
Kensington but also the new institution
and all of our activities we are working
to serve up the tools the means of
thinking about how we act and operate
within the world today it's about
thinking about the network digitized
world and our role within it what is our
agency I think often we think that we
are just passive consumers but consumers
are not passive and I think that is what
we as an institution and a museum and a
public space can make hay with or bring
into discussion it's that radical zeal
of our foundation which we're using is
the legs on which to peddle this idea
it's about going beyond novel or the
beautiful to think about objects in the
round the title of our exhibition all of
this belongs to you is a very knowing
choice we hold objects in public trust
the same as the case in the US when you
go to a museum those objects are yours
what should those institutions be doing
with them that is the challenge today
it's a call to arms in some ways as well
on my part because I think we make
things we use things but what does that
mean it's always that question of
bringing about more thoughtful consumers
but also more thoughtful designers we
shape the world and the world shapes us
we need to be active in that engagement
and that's me done in terms of talking
I'm aware that some of the questions
around actual collecting archiving
digitizing might be some of the things
that you may have questions around
but yes please do ask questions if you
have them I think we have three minutes
flappy bird and the phone that might not
work yeah it seems like the crude
reality of lots of the technology
nowadays that it dies very quickly very
fragile not like you know the moment
statues that we're leaving for like
centuries how do you preserve this
fragile of torque or maybe you should
not preserve a maybe it's about children
counting the death of technology as more
as an expression of it there are the
questions that um feature in my well you
might argue that the museum already is
the cemetery of those things we have
product design in our collections and I
don't mean that exclusively to the VNA
but we have product design from the
nineteen hundreds through to today that
has never been used in some way it's
boxfresh it's in some ways never been
alive you might argue the view name
since has had this process in place and
that's not one that my colleagues and I
have yet sought to change but we always
acquire two objects that you can switch
on so we have one that remains never
used and one that you can interact with
as a visitor if you were to ask to have
a go and that's the future proofing of
objects with an interface at the moment
by no means is that appropriate or
long-lasting I think this question of
what we are obliged to reserve preserve
is one that is ever-changing and the
fact that the obsolescence of objects is
ever-increasing is the greatest concern
for us institutionally how we go about
that is a vast vast question and it's
about the thinking about what we acquire
in terms of the actual object itself how
we acquire around the object to make
sure that we have the social political
economic
text around the object so with flappy
bird you might say it's about having
documentary evidence of the frustrations
it's about the death threats that were
happening to Dong Ling the designer it's
about flushing out that entirety of the
story making sure that the object is
playable in some form I would like to
think that we can always have it on a
piece of hardware that is in period time
with the design of the game but I have
to acknowledge that that is very
unlikely to be possible in museums in
terms of digitization of their
collections are quite far advanced in
terms of preserving and storing digital
things we are still very much catching
up at the VNA we are still working
without a digital conservator or media
technologist which i think is quite own
it is something that will absolutely
change in the next number of years
emulation is the way that most
institutions are going forward but it's
always a different experience the one
that you had at the first point and is
it then that we begin to collect around
that experience to make sure that that
but museums also have to be do we
collect more objects and less of the
singular object or do we now start to
collect so vastly around every object
that we acquire that we are less able to
take a broad spectrum and those are
resource questions which frustratingly
do impact on how we work and operate
these fascinating czar and here's how
the meantime the initiation of that
position because it is too early then
maybe the context have not been served
it but it was too late it may not be
relevant and you cannot know that before
and response that's a very particular
question in other terms of collecting
it's never quite so critical so how we
go about knowing what we want to acquire
for rapid response is either very
reactive as in we read an article in the
newspaper or we see that Zino has just
plummet
it or it's about saying I know that
graphene is this incredible new material
I don't want to acquire it in what it is
because that is maybe more what the
science museum might do but I do know
that they are working extremely hard to
make commercial products and so I've
been following the graphene story very
closely and I know that a light bulb is
probably going to be the first product
that will be the point of time when I
think we will acquire it what we acquire
and how we acquire is always both about
the design process the object and then
it's kind of market or social political
impact there are objects where I think
we've missed the boat in terms of rapid
response where I don't think we can
include them which is a very kind of
fluid and vague sense but it is the case
we've now been asked and challenged to
think back how might you do this idea
rapid response collecting with the long
tail of history so an example that I
always come back to there is the Afghan
war rugs where you start seeing rugs
being made with weaponry and tanks that
would be a brilliant rapid response
object at the time do we acquire that on
those terms now we're not at the moment
that doesn't mean we won't the context
is always there the thing with rapid
response is it's that moment in time and
getting it into the museum in some way
with in touch of that many of these
objects and actually all of these
objects have to have a meaning in the
museum and in the collection beyond
rapid response because they are designed
things it's not that this is an activity
of collecting material culture which i
think would slightly change the dynamic
response funny you would be on something
that is entirely digital a good example
is my colleagues here in computer
science his name's Keith Wilson created
a 6-line algorithm that was one of the
first essentially decrypt dvds back in
the days when they sort of brought the
motion picture industry to its knees and
you know by distributing this sort of
almost office gated
you could then you know play any DVD and
rip it to your hard drive and so on and
so this thing had cultural significance
it's sort of brief and then there was
there was even isn't at the point where
the thing crosses over in a musical
world like they made a time with the
code on it and that thing that ty was
auctioned for having $25,000 last year
or something like this and wondering
like where where is this line for your
group yes it's it's one that we don't
have an answer to yet and I think we
need to be comfortable with that again
also because I don't think there is one
answer objects that are solely digital I
mean code yes absolutely we should and
will be collecting it but I think we
have to think of these objects and how
we exhibit them and we just need to get
better exhibiting things that are solely
digital in we chat is this social media
platform which we are now beginning to
acquire we have mon 1 which is a soft
toy was a sticker we will be collecting
the stickers alongside the actual code
of that platform but there's no way that
we can collect it in its entirety just
in terms of the digital designed piece
but also the user interaction and the
apps within the app that are being
designed by others we always have to
draw a line but we need to have these
things in the collection now and at the
same time become more sophisticated in
within the way that we exhibit them I
think if we hold fire until we know how
we will have missed the boat this
question about the tie we the number of
objects we acquire and the number of
objects we discuss is very very
different and when we first started with
rapid response it was so often yes
there's a great story we now need to
find the object and it never works
because we're about material things but
also designed things so for example and
this is again a very uk-based example
but we had a referendum for Scottish
independence and it was like we must
find an object around this we even put a
had a news story run in the majors
Scottish papers and we was offered up
a blackboard that was used to write the
numbers of yes and no cupcake sold in
the 90 days prior to the referendum
interesting in a brilliant example of
how you might think about a popular
discourse around the referendum but
absolutely not a design thing having
given that more thought and if we had
been a bit quicker and smarter we might
have acquired the actual ballot paper
because that was an incredible piece of
economy of design the way the words were
chosen which is not necessarily designed
in the terms of how we might understand
it here but it was also about how it was
laid out on the page that was the object
that we should have acquired there are
lots of objects that have been suggested
that to my mind don't quite make it like
Malala Yusef school uniform on the day
that she was shot that was put on
display in the Nobel Center when she was
nominated or even received the award for
me that was an object of material
culture or historical significance in no
way was the design of that thing the
lead interest but that digital design I
mean we've had a digital department at
the museum for three years and so it's
one of those things that we are skilling
up on I'm really happy and keen to be
given and suggested objects of that
nature because the more that I have to
work with the more we can bring about
change in the institution and that's one
of the things that's very very important
and maybe I didn't emphasize enough with
rapid response we are fully aware that
as curators today we are not going to be
the experts on everything and all things
and rapid responses about that
conversation it's about saying think
about the world but also help us to
think about the world with you and
through you and so we offer we want
people to come and suggest objects to us
so it's about inviting in expertise in
all terms and the others I mean we're
also working on a video games exhibition
which is the beginnings of the longer
term engagement with the design
narrative that is so important with in
gaming and video games and there is a
brilliant set of communities that are
always going to be better than us as an
institution in documenting prison
maintaining video games and I think as
an institution we need to embrace the
more digital attitude be more open more
sharing more collaborative and that in
many ways goes against what lots of
institutions historical approach has
been and if you just think about images
and access and rights to images or
scholarship you know it's about
retention as opposed to sharing and that
shift is happening and it has to happen
in terms of collecting exhibiting etc
history of competing museum bless thee
park there's a reconstruction of the
process muscle they took them about ten
years to reconstruct how to be
reconstructed because they rule smashed
up after the war but very very important
because that's what the code breaking
the double stand against germs and then
yesterday we were at the computer
history museum here where they've got an
IBM 1401 I've been very important
computer of its time it's what you know
it's your 60s it is on the computer and
they actually found a complete one and
it took the volunteers there 17 years to
reconstruct if it works also won't be a
stripper it doesn't work I was wondering
these are two sort of massive
enterprises you know spending almost 20
years to get an idea moving around to
work again a very important six-year-old
computable reconstructing the king
computer that helped us win the Second
World War I mean do you think there's a
sense of enterprises the making things
of history work again and most of those
cases because their digital devices you
know it isn't just a few people spends
that spend here doing it and when they
had about 30 people working for 17 years
you liken it to the flying scotsman
which is one of our great esteem engines
having just been brought back into
service and it taking a great deal of
time a great deal of fun i'm going to
slightly skirt your question and say
mind ever working in the contemporary is
to try and avoid
that happening in the future and that's
the approach that I have I think in
terms of digital objects and making ones
of the past work again I think it's
interesting but if I had to place my my
efforts I would place them elsewhere I
think there is born digital artwork
there are very many objects in
collections where you cannot understand
the artwork without the function of
these period pieces and I think that's
where you will often find the greatest
endeavor to make those things work again
and I think again it's about the sharing
and exchanging expertise that might be
the best thing how many of those IBM
computers we need to bring back into
service across the globe would be
another one of those questions
you